another blood sample for Antoine
mijangam humble it's a monthly routine
in a medical study late last year the 22
year old was given an experimental Ebola
vaccine since then he and his blood have
been carefully monitored whoa that's how
I find out if I'm doing all right and
that can help people in the affected
areas here initial Jose Fernandez is a
physician working in the study he's
monitoring 60 volunteers in the village
of lambarena for decades here in the
forests of Gabon a lively exchange has
been going on between German and
Japanese scientists the research center
is right next to the hospital that Nobel
Peace Prize winner Albert Schweitzer
once founded the first phase of the
study tests dosages and their
tolerability Fernandez interrupted work
on his doctorate in Germany to join the
study it was a easy decision to make
because it is an important challenge and
it's in terms of science really really
useful and important to get a strong
vaccine against these disease the
volunteers blood is screened in the lab
no problems yet in the study's second
phase the vaccines effectiveness is
supposed to be tested and countries
affected by Ebola in this refrigerator
the candidate vaccine is stored at 81
degrees below zero it's the big hope of
the scientists in the fight against
Ebola should all tests be successful
they might soon be the need of much
larger quantities the experimental Ebola
vaccine is called v sv z Bob it's been
genetically modified to carry a surface
protein of the Ebola virus that's
supposed to help vaccinated people
develop antibodies to the feared
pathogen
that's the theory the clinical study is
being conducted in various locations in
the US Europe and Africa and coordinated
by the World Health Organization in
Gabon the researchers work closely with
specialists from the Institute of
tropical medicine in tubigon the nomana
things that normally take years and now
being done in months the Namara isn't
monitored on things that normally took
months are being done within weeks yet
formed it's all being co-ordinated by
the wh 0 and that's why everything could
be accomplished so quickly ging one
source near indian contr jose fernandez
is proud to be playing his part in this
important study in an historic location
he says it makes him proud to be part of
the legacy of the famous German doctor
and missionary Albert Schweitzer when
you work in this hospital you cannot
forget what he has done here and we have
it in mind everything Lee so far it's
too early to conclude about the outcome
of this project but we are confident
really soon we get strong results
reliable enough to conclude something Dr
Fernandez helps the results can be
released within weeks if the Ebola
vaccine is found to be safe for people's
health vaccinations can then begin in
regions affected by the disease